-Our next guest
is a talented actress you know
from shows like "Dirty John"
and "Little Birds"
and films such as "Palmer"
and "The Dark Knight Rises."
She stars in the award-winning
series "Ted Lasso,"
which is available in
its entirety on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-Next picture of me
will not be this perfect.
I am gonna be mid-sneeze face,
like -- [ Gasps ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
Guess what the headline will be.
-"Gesundheit"?
-"Jamie's tart
breaks Tartt's heart."
-Did you just
come up with that?
-Yeah.
-Everyone would read that.
-Of course they would!
I mean, you have no idea
the power of rhyming
in this goddamn country!
-Yeah.
-Ooh, "Lasso makes passo
and creates team fiasco."
-Whoa! Keeley's got bars.
-Please welcome to the sho
Juno Temple.
How are you, Juno?
-Hi! I'm good!
I'm so excited
to be virtually with you.
-I am equally excited
This is a show that brough
so many people joy
at a time
when they needed it so much.
Was it as joyous to make
as it was to watch?
-Genuinely.
And continues to be throughout
shooting season two, as well
It's actually -- I don't know.
Playing Keeley
throughout this past six month
has just been
a true injection of joy.
And what an amazing thing
that the show has touched people
the way it has.
Because, yeah, it has been
a roller coaster of heaven
to make it,
to be honest with you.
-Is it true that when
Jason Sudeikis
first reached out to you
about the part,
you thought
that he had made a mistake
-Yes, I did.
Yeah, I got a text message
from him
saying that there was a pilo
that I might be interested
in reading,
and I genuinely thought
that he potentially had texted
the wrong actress
because I'm definitely not known
for my comedic roles.
I tend to play
much more dramatic roles
where women are really
going through a lot
and trying to figure out
what's happening
in their future whilst
dealing with their past,
all that kind of stuff.
So, yeah, luckily,
he did text me on purpose.
And that was an
embarrassing conversation
that I didn't
have to go through.
But an amazing one.
Because I'm still
kind of shocked
that he even thought of me
for this role at all.
And I'm very grateful for it
-I've heard from
a lot of friends of mine
that they love the show
because they can watch it
with their whole family.
I know that your friends,
your family watch it,
and this hasn't been the cas
with all of your work
that it is friendly
for the people you know.
-No, this is very true.
I have two younger brothers --
one who's four years
younger than me
and one that's ten years younger
than me --
and, you know,
they definitely don't rush
to tell their best friends
when their sister is playing
the lesbian werewolf
who has to masturbate in bed
and kick out a werewolf...
you know?
Or,you know, just taking
my clothes off a lot,
to which I'm very okay with,
but definitely don't need
to put my brothers
through that experience
or their friends.
And I've had slightly
awkward moments, you know,
saying hi to some of
my brothers' friends,
and they were kind of,
"Oh, hi. It's nice to see you.
How you doing?
Yeah, uh, liked your new job
movie, fi-- uh, thing.
Well done." [ Laughs ]
-"Yeah, it's nice to see you
For the first time ever!"
[ Laughter ]
This is something that's
interesting about your brothers.
So, I'm a father now.
I got two kids.
I feel like your dad
is living my nightmare,
which is he roots for
the football club Arsenal,
and yet your brothers
root for Chelsea.
Is he so depressed by this
or has he come to terms with it?
-You know what? Actually,
you would think it would b
World War III in the house
when there are matches of thos
two teams against each other
but they're also
very artistic people.
So there is this sense of calm
normally in my house.
We're listening to a lot o
great music, dance a lot.
Yeah, I grew up with a ver
kind of liberal household.
But then there is this sort of
inner hooligan that comes ou
that only football can
really draw out of anybody
And so for me,
rather than me paying attentio
to the battle
going on between them,
I'm like, "Who are these
strangers in my household?!"
[ Laughs ]
But I will say that when Arsenal
is playing somebody else,
my brothers will root
for Arsenal with my father
and then vice versa
with Chelsea.
So, for example, when Chelse
won a couple of weekends ago
which both my brothers
were at Stamford Bridge
in tears overjoyed
with that result,
my dad was
incredibly happy for them.
-I think that speaks
to a very strong family unit
you have,
that you can celebrate.
-Yes.
-If my brother,
or should I say, if my kid
root for a different team,
I will not feel
any joy for them, only misery.
-Who's your team?
-Well, West Ham
is my football club, so...
-[ Gasps ] Yuck!
-Yeah. See?
-That is tough...my friend
[ Laughter ]
-Look. You think
I'm happy about it?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm actually slightly
silenced for a minute with that.
-That's all right.
You know what?
I'll let you just digest that.
-I'm going to reminisce
from that from you.
I'm over it. It's cool.
-So I want to ask.
"Little Birds."
This new project you have. Sor
of the opposite of "Ted Lasso.
Tell us a bit about that.
-Yeah, it's definitely
a completely different world
We're going back in time
to the 1950s
and set in Tangier in Morocc
in the 1950s.
And it's loosely inspired
by Anais Nin's "little birds."
So it's all actually
kind of exploring erotica.
And I think people will
really get a model sometimes
and think that sort of
sex appeal
and being sexy and eroticism
are the same thing,
but I think they're
very different actually.
I think sexiness is somethin
that you're normally
quite aware of.
You're aware of
creating it, of doing it,
whereas eroticism is about stuff
that goes on internally
that people normally get
a little bit uncomfortable
talking about or a lot
uncomfortable talking about.
And that's something
that I loved about the boo
initially, "Little Birds."
I read when I was really young
And then this project
when it came into my universe.
And the director that made it,
Stacie Passon,
and how great she was
about exploring all of that,
especially, you know,
being completely unafraid
to ask questions about all o
our feelings about [Stammers
Eroticism. Whoa.
Sorry bout that.
-And, so, is this one for
your brother and his friends
or is this one maybe --
-There is a little bit
of nipple in this one.
So it comes with a warning
for sure.
Actually. You know what?
Any time my nipples are in it,
they're actually painted.
So one time, they're blue,
and one time,
they're kind of
pale blue and glittery,
so that might mean that's okay
-Yeah, I think that's
certainly right on the line.
-Thanks.
-Yeah.
-Sort of like bra
in a weird way.
-Well, I'm very excited
that everyone can see that soon,
and I'm equally excited
that "Ted Lasso"
is coming back for season two.
Delightful talking to you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-"Little Birds"
airs Sundays on Starz.
And the second season
of "Ted Lasso" premieres
July 23rd on Apple TV+.